we have heard from the introductions in
the the backgrounds of the people
sitting around the table
there are numerous interests and
numerous starting points or ways to
connect to issues of water of community
of access and and so the range of
disciplinary interests I find quite
fascinating and in terms of the work
that I've been doing with curriculum and
really speaks to this notion of
interdisciplinarity and some folks use
the term transdisciplinarity but in some
ways when we're interested in in key
issues social issues those disciplines
go away it's about people it's about
it's about something beyond science or
beyond art or beyond whatever that
discipline might be so our multiple
areas of expertise really come into play
quite nicely here this year not only do
I have the pleasure to and the good
fortune to be able to visit three times
here at MIT is a MIT is a visiting
artist but I'm also a visiting artist
and visiting learner at a local
elementary school back home and I'm
essentially people were asking what are
you doing at MIT and what are you doing
at the elementary school and I said I'm
doing the same thing yeah and the key is
I'm going I want to know at the
elementary school specifically what they
can teach me about what I think I know
about what I'm doing and that's what
we're doing here - I'm eager to learn
about what you can teach me about what I
think I'm doing but also what we can
teach each other what we can learn from
each other quite often in some
educational spaces administrators
teachers other folks in various levels
of making decisions
forget explicitly or otherwise that
learners bring knowledge with them to
every single learning context so there's
as much learning going on in one
direction as there are in multiple
directions so we all have valuable
information to share so I'm eager to
have that conversation so it's about the
filters right it's about how these
ceramic water filters inspire multiple
curriculum possibilities it's not just a
curriculum or instructional
possibilities for how do you make the
filter and how do you use them but there
are other other ripples pardon the pun
right there are other ways that the the
filters might inspire learning for
example the filters are designed to sit
inside a plastic water receptacle like
the one you see here and the one you saw
in the video but what if you asked
artists to create a ceramic receptacle
in their own style you gave them the
specifications and they created the
vessel in their own style and then you
could actually have an exhibition of
these receptacles and that exhibition
could tour two different locations and
in doing so you could promote the
exhibition but you could also then talk
about the global water crisis you could
talk about that lack of adequate access
to water you could talk about the ways
that artists and other folks are
engaging in work to respond to these
issues anytime and so these exhibitions
went on for a number of years with my
colleagues and I were talking about
reviving this practice the idea is if
someone purchases one of the receptacles
that money essentially is a donation
back to a water project this is a vessel
that I created as part of that work and
it's inspired by the sanitation workers
strike in 1968 I am a man and it relates
in many ways to found object art
assemblage work from some of the
modernist artists that's a top of a
trophy I found at a secondhand store
with a guy with a little fedora it
wasn't perfect right and I made these
little signs but the idea being how can
the work of art itself function as a way
to speak out and speak back to social
issues inspired by this one was inspired
by the water filters and water filter
receptacles so those links become
interred become entangled but they also
allow for other trajectories of thinking
to happen
you know we can talk about protests we
can talk about well what is a basic
human need what is a human right what is
what is privileged what are you what do
you what do you need and what do you
want those are two different things and
I think those kinds of conversations
with students are quite powerful
who has access who who sets up the
limitations what is necessary who takes
action right these kinds of questions I
think are central to not only a creek
curricula within education within art or
thin education but also curricula within
the various disciplines that are
represented around this table I'm
leaving on the 13th to go to Puerto Rico
to two central mountain towns Sidra to
bring you know solar lamps water filters
and solar panels and solar panel kits to
a certain sector of of a bottle and see
that I so so the idea of like you know a
filter that you know if it's in a
luggage right because I'm limited to
what I can personally carry three
50-pound bags or in paying $75 for the
third one to free whatever to do that
because the bothersome part for me who
this is not my background I know I don't
know so we have rechargeable batteries
at home that we've been very true to
like we only use our chargeable battery
since as far as that goes with us but um
and then the filter water inside it but
um
waters pretty good but seeing all these
shipments of bottled water and the
requests for batteries in an island and
just the waste that that will create um
and and then no one thinks about and how
can at least in one corner of the world
or in this case that island can you know
we try to do something cuz you know I
talked to my family and they go to the
river and that's where they bathe and
that's where they get water it's a clean
and clean and me that's
because they won't drink it because they
don't know if something died absolutely
further up mountain and and and they
don't have you know access to that and
there's Sun everywhere right so uh so
just that immediate thing and it's
caustic locator because at the bottom of
the hill there's a huge hardware type of
like a mostly safe in it that he I like
you know just like a lumberyard type of
thing so and you say sawdust I'm like oh
I can get tons of sawdust from the it
they from a high low Barrios but um but
yeah that that on the access and and how
you know in a limited timeframe can one
you know I look at that little one right
there on just to just to do that right
because of right and weights nothing
there's nothing yeah so so I guess
that's my of this and and then I see um
oh geez go like who has Hartford I'm
from Hartford so he has Hartford roots
and and you know what they Dred Scott
like you know it's it's a really
exciting presentation and contextualize
does it really incredibly but this
really drew me because of the immediacy
of what's happening out there
absolutely yeah well you know what we're
seeing in Puerto Rico right now is just
for me it's beyond words beyond
adjectives like it's it's indescribable
I spoke with a friend of mine a
colleague and friend of mine a few days
ago his family is in political energy
citizens know he talked about before we
heard the reports in the news about the
gas issues and the water issues he told
me about both of those I also appreciate
your comment about you know sending
water bottles and batteries and that
just creates more waste it's helpful but
unless you think about what happens
beyond the life of that material that's
being irresponsible at some level right
so the rechargeable the recycle will
renew
is important yeah these little filters
are made from the same mixture as the
large filters they're just on a smaller
scale you see in the back on that table
we we made some mini filters yesterday
we still have some clay and sawdust we
can make some more today if you want the
day with these they would need to be
tested right to make sure that they have
the proper flow rate but the other thing
is you'd have to we have to make sure
that the water that is there that these
filters would filter out the bad stuff
in the water that's there okay so you
know I'm happy to make some small
filters if you'd like to take some with
you and you'd have to see but you also
need to take some test kits and I have
some small test kits if I don't have
them here I have them we can get them we
can get them to you but the idea is that
you need to test the water it's it would
be equally irresponsible say oh here's
something that can be you know to take
with you and it doesn't work so we have
to figure out what's in the water and
that's the basis for setting up the
filter facilities but the idea of being
able to take some of these in your
backpack and on your carry-on and being
able to distribute and have immediate
response that's that's a big deal and so
you know what you're up to and what then
the work that you're going to be doing
you know it's very important there's a
another C's things are fragile too so
the packing that it would take would
require taking up some space as well so
there's always give and take push and
pull one I was talking to someone
yesterday about a very similar part of
the conversation and one of the things
we started to do when I was at Texas A&M
before I came to Penn State where I'm
with the Penn State was revolving around
this very thing and we thought you know
what I borrowed a bottle for just a
second this opening is about the same
size as larger bottles I don't have one
here see like a liter bottle what if we
turned it over and you cut it right here
or you cut it just enough that you could
have a little flap right and then what
if we took the same material and instead
of what some folks are doing with making
disks look they look like hockey pucks
right that you can put inside PVC piping
well if we made little corks they look
like little wine corks but it's made out
of this material that could fit into
this bottle so you lift the hinge you
put the cork down there and then we have
our own little portable receptacle so it
would take this bottle that then gets
discarded that creates waste maybe it
becomes a repurposed individual how many
corks could you yeah you're just
creating quart how many wine corks could
you take in your backpack hundreds right
so it's that notion of scale and
responsibility and access and immediacy
maybe after you know a couple of weeks
or maybe in this case unfortunately a
couple of months the the there would not
be that need and you'd have ways to deal
with the recycling but anyway what
you're talking about is a very important
issue instead of concerns
I first became familiar with the term
creative disruption from David darts who
was a educator and his doctoral
dissertation and work looking at the
practice of culture jamming which grows
out of an entire practice of responding
to capitalism and advertising so David
looked at this idea of visual culture
jamming where you add create instead of
looking at culture specific broadly
called visual culture more specifically
and the way one might look at the visual
components of a culture differently
through some sort of what he called
creative disruption creative meaning you
know to put in come his sense coming
from an artistic or cultural production
perspective but yeah you know that you
can be disruptive one might argue you
know any kind of disruption Idzik is
creative but certainly the creative in
this sense comes from a more generic
notion of artistic how many decades ago
what no no yes it's only but determines
about 15-20 years old in the sense that
I understand it today it's been a very
popular tournament in business
management it's part of business school
that I've been teaching courses in
creative disruption as a strategy for
entrepreneurship so if you want to take
on the big companies you need to do
something that disrupts the whole logic
of how that whatever that service or
product is is organized and presented
part of the work that I do at my current
university and previous universities in
art education is to prepare teachers to
prepare teachers of art but even Kate
k12 teachers and so with that
preparation their courses method methods
courses or curriculum development
courses that essentially are structured
to respond in many ways to very specific
skills or content and that's all fine
good except you know what I find more
interesting are the the questions that
emerge and that can be Center points for
for curriculum so instead of thinking of
curriculum development as and management
it's the idea of theorizing curriculum
so spinning it around in terms of the
questioning most teacher preparation
programs that I'm familiar with because
there are the these standards and and
and points for accreditation students
must meet specific responses and they're
pretty rigid there's those curricula but
I think that there are ways to play in
and around I've worked this way for a
while
round the Y by still responding to those
expectations for certification but at
the same time open it up so that
teachers become knowledgeable and
prepared and have experience to have an
ongoing engagement with with with with
learning and developing interesting and
exciting curricula that responds to
social practices for example
the idea of focusing on a theme or a
concept or a question rather than on a
specific outcome or skill just making
that shift is a big challenge for a lot
of teacher preparation programs because
what you're doing is you're essentially
saying the the predetermined content
that we have in the predetermined skills
that we have is not all there is to our
discipline that there could be more to
it and it also suggests that it's not
really the the the the the idea of
learning that's important in education
it's about teaching content so I like to
turn also the shift to from teaching to
learning to making the project about
learning know and so this is how how I'm
going about it myself Larry working with
undergrads and grad students to put
questions at the center of their
curriculum so it becomes an inquiry
based approach or it becomes a thematic
approach and often it's inspired by by
social issues I can show you an example
or two if you'd like and specifically to
water so one of the things that I've
enjoyed doing is using you know we've
had back and forth Larry about you know
access to education and broad spaces
online is one way that that happens so
mindmeister is a free application and
some of my early work in curriculum
theorizing and development looked at a
hypertext spatial hypertext so what if
you took a concept like in more than a
concept I mean you know water is a broad
idea big so what if we put water at the
center here and what I did was I said
look at a group of students we said if
we put water at the center what are the
ideas and questions and concepts that
emerge from just us thinking about water
so there might be technology concerns
their issues related to pollution there
are contemporary artists who are looking
at in thinking about water there are
there's information then at the next
level that relates to our understandings
of water and so what you're seeing here
is an interconnected web of information
inspired by the simple notion of water
what if you as a teacher as it you can
be a teacher you can be an artist you
can whatever
what is art water make you think of what
questions emerged what do you know about
water what are you curious about about
water if you start curriculum in that
place what do you know what don't you
know what would be interesting to know
and you go off in these various
dimensions and you start to learn along
you along the way and you're not doing
it by yourself you're learning with a
group of people so everyone in class has
access to this Web everyone in class
over the series of days that we're
working on this can see how it continues
to be populated and we all have access
to everybody else's information this is
a curriculum right here of water that
could be navigated that could be you
know you could select certain components
of it again I'm not showing you all of
the details but you could select certain
components of it highlight those
components there might be some key
questions you might like some of the
things that one person looked at and so
here are some issues about pollution
sanitation and civilizations this
correct this piece also allows us to put
embedded video and another content so
the idea would be if the preparation of
teachers where the work that teachers do
as they prepare to be certified and
licensed moves away specific Ahsan
discipline content only on discipline
skills but privileges the questioning
and and the nurturing of inquiry and
learning I think what we have is we have
a different sensibility you have
teachers who aren't limited by their own
disciplines and are seeking ways to make
those those connections and in doing
that a curriculum that comes from this
mode of development can then respond to
any state or local standards of learning
any national curriculum concerns example
I want to show you this is given to a
Elementary
art exhibit and you see like all of the
images are look very similar you see
like you know all the paintings and
their drawings whatever rarely did we
see art criticism we rarely do you see
young children's art historical papers
on display
happens every less while this is a water
filter display at the Chester field
Chesterfield County exhibition so this
is just one teacher Sean Collins did
this and so he used the water filters as
part of his curriculum but also as part
of the art exhibition he got comments
from teams like wow like how does this
art this is part of your art great well
yet why not this is what we're doing and
he linked it to Greek vases and he
linked it to an expressionist painting
he leaked it to all sorts of other
components but by making the art
curriculum or the space in which an
artist might think inclusive of
appropriate technology and social issues
and social responsibility
that's a disruption right there so can
elementary kids do it absolutely they
can this is a page from the reservoir
studio including names of the the art
teachers who have agreed to work with me
or found interest or that have invited
me to do water filter performances but
also work on curricula with them and
this list keeps growing I haven't
updated yet but I have several others
who have been interested here's a person
who came to a conference curriculum
conference Denis Corps and she was a
science educator in Texas she came to
this curriculum and pedagogy conference
instead of presenting a paper on the
water filters my colleague and my mentor
Richard woo Kitsch and I we set up a
water filter production facility and we
made filters as our conference
presentation and so people coming and
expecting to see a paper presented they
helped me save sawdust and we made the
filters reason I'm telling you that is
because Denis Gordon showed up to that
presentation and she said I am a science
teacher but I think in these
interdisciplinary ways and I like these
experiencial hands-on approaches and so
I sent her four filters
mini filters at her request to that had
silver on embedded in them and to that
did not and her advanced science
students middle school students did
tests
on those water filters they tested the
water from two local sources they did
research on the production of the
filters and they set up they found other
commercial filters and they they ran
their results and they found that the
these little filters worked as well or
better than those commercial filters on
two different sources of water one was I
think the local river and the other was
some other sewage space but my point is
that she empowered her students to take
control and to and to lead the inquiry
and this is middle school so can middle
school students think in these ways and
consider their place in the world in
their responsibility absolutely and
again these are just two of many
possible ways that this might happen but
just just responding specifically to to
that question probably what is existing
taking it ahead and improving on it may
be called incremental and disruptive
where you put a full stop and start with
something here in fact ceramic filter
itself I don't know whether to call it
disruptive because a filter existed and
it was modified in some ways so I'm
really confused about these definitions
about disruptive incremental what is it
and how do you move back especially in
terms of disasters where I think the
need is to go back to basics from a
disruption is incremental to process
it's a it's a verb in my my thinking
certainly one can disrupt with a
specific action and it seems like it's
only happening in that moment but we can
think more broadly that once that moment
happens there's there continuing echoes
from that so I I think it's also
site-specific to the degree of
incremental change or disruption that
happens but I don't I'm not thinking
about disruption necessarily as as one
specific moment I think of in a longer
term in a moving time-based way I so
that's one part of your question I think
the second part had to do with the
filters and seeing them as disruptive
and certainly for folks who didn't have
adequate access to clean water and now
they might
have access the filters have disrupted
that previous narrative of
inaccessibility and have disrupted a
long-standing a generational experience
with being sick and and and having
disease right so so it's disrupting that
that health issue in that human issue
and and and so there's that and then
going back to basic absolutely I mean
you do what you need to do and certainly
you know the water's coming down let's
get some plastic and collect the water I
mean that that seems like the most
appropriate technology that we've talked
about today right I think your examples
are right on right on and I hope it
clarified a little bit how I'm thinking
about disruption that is and I didn't
clarify disruption for me it's not a
moment but it's an ongoing it's a
continuum absolutely yeah disruptive or
non destructive my job is to provide
clean water to people around it and
that's what I'm doing so that it is
disruptive or not it's that simple
well yeah it is yeah yeah and I think
sometimes I like to be a bit more
dramatic maybe then necessary but
certainly and and to think more broadly
or differently you know folks didn't
have the water and you allow water to be
available you disrupted their their lack
of access so you did your job
you